vacation just for clarification if and
when we see a Conservative government
and then Mr Cameron decides not to run
in 2020 would you like to be Prime
Minister well in by 2020 you know yes no
we're fine well the answer is by 2020 I
will be you know I hope I'll still be
alive and still in Parliament but there
will be the kaleidoscope of politics
would have changed rotated there will be
all sorts of many possibilities of
leader the Conservative Party I would
like David Cameron to lead us to would
you would you keep your office don't
don't rule out the possibility of I
think a very considerable conservative
success on on medicine I really really
like to potentially be considered as the
leader of the Conservative Party when
mr. Cameron is no longer there well you
know it's not yes okay it's not
something that is top of my agenda nog
was probably my top of my agenda now is
to get David Cameron elected yeah well
as we discussed I think only you know 10
minutes ago
ten minutes ago without saying no if
that is at least five years away which
is a which is a lot I shouldn't be on in
British politics by which time whatever
my whatever my personal ambitions may be
there will there will be thrusting young
when men and women who will be
overtaking me in who knows so it'll be
different but the priority is is to is
to have a successful election on on
medicine and I am genuinely you know
walking around talking to people it
doesn't feel like 2001 dumped in May
2005 it's better than 2010 you know I
really I reminds me a bit of them you
want to be Terminator you don't you've
got so much Flair and four nails about
you and yet you can't when you actually
nails out you won't stay yes I don't
like it when Cameron's not there anymore
I want you there I'm here to explain
that first of all Alex Salmond groaning
in my ear in the gallery
look that's say answer the question is
what they're saying hi what's your words
yes or no what do you want to be
conservative leader after Cameron's not
anymore well in the dim distant future
obviously it would be wonderful thing to
be thought to be in a position to be
considered for such a long but I think
it's highly unlikely as I've said many
many times before that you know it's
more likely I will be reincarnated as an
olive or blinded by a champagne cork or
locked in a disused pretty mini high by
the time we're going to have to leave it
there thank you for joining us here and
thank you